so we have another transformers movie in
the making and this one will be one for
the ages
since they will be focusing on
transformers that will turn to giant
monsters
so in this video we will list down the
transformers that are confirmed and the
ones that are possibly going to make an
appearance
in rise of the bees and this will be a
sequel to bumblebee
and a prequel to the first transformers
movie in the premise it is the year 1994
and two humans partner with
optimus prime and the autobots as they
come into an ancient conflict that ties
in with three factions of transformers
yes not just autobots and decepticons
but other factions that will include the
terracons and the maximals
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's dive into the beastly
transformers that will
be seen here firstly the terracons
the confirmed ones and these will take
the place of decepticons as baddies
so the first one is kosh and he is a
fierce and merciless and an impeccable
hunter
created from the remains of
thundercracker he leads a wolf pack
of tracker terminators designed to hunt
down autobots well in other continuities
he possesses powerful high-tech scanning
equipment and
a disintegrated array that can cut
through rock
then we have knight bird another
terracon nightbot is a transformer that
turns into a nissan gtr sports car and
would probably be a rival to bumblebee
although not a part of the main
terracons in other continuities
knight bird will most definitely be one
to watch for
now the main terracones in most
continuities and also possibly
that will appear in the movie the first
one hunger
here's the actual leader of the
terracones this guy transforms into a
two-headed dragon
and also he loves to eat anything made
of metal even enemy bullets so
there might be a reveal later between
hunger and scourge as who leads the
terracons
then we have blood which transforms into
a mole-like creature and is said to be
the least
intelligent of the terracons and we hope
the next one
called cutthroat to also make a debut
appearance in the live action movies
and this transformer is a merciless
hunter and transforms into a flying
dinosaur or maybe a pterosaur
then ripper snapper this transformer is
primal in nature and will eat and attack
anything that moves even terror counts
on occasions
he is said to transform into a land
shark whatever that is
then cinnaton this proud terracon is one
to behold he transforms into an arthur's
type monster
he is an exploring warrior who always
looks for new enemies to
fight which means autobots and maximals
in the next movie
then lastly abominus even more dangerous
than the decepticon combiners like
infernicus
abominus is a being made of mindless
fury
he's not truly a warrior but an animal
the destructive rages of all the
terrorcons that compose him personified
he might appear as the final antagonist
of the movie
now we come to the maximals or at least
the confirmed ones
the first one is optimus primal so this
one is the leader of the maximals and
the captain of the cybertronian
spaceship axelon
his beast mode is a giant gorilla he had
a rivalry with the predator megatron in
the beast walls
and it is still unclear as to if primal
will be optimus prime himself
or yet another transformer then we have
air razor
the smallest one of the confirmed
maximals air razor is going to be in the
air
and will transform into a falcon she
will be in charge of air reconnaissance
and
in beast wars she combines with
tigertron to become the more powerful
tiger hop
then we have rhinops this is a
transformer that was first seen in beast
walls universe
he is the second in command and a
subcommander of the maximals
his beast mode is a large rhinoceros and
we think that he will be the muscle of
the maximals
and so we go to the maximals that are
not confirmed but are
possibly going to appear in the movie we
have
rat trap and he is a member of the
maximals and he took the role of a
leader when
optimus primal was abducted by aliens
his beast mode is a rat and he became
the trans medal
he has a tendency to give his comrades
nicknames
then we go to dynabot he was originally
a member of the predacons but later
joined the maximals
his beast mode is a velociraptor and he
lives by his
own code of honor he often fought with
rat trap who called him
chopper phase and he sacrificed himself
by saving an early human village from a
break on attack
at least in the beast wars continuity
then we have black arachnia
she is a combat specialist and of
covered ops
she started out as a member of the
predacons and her beast mode is a black
widow spider
she was created by tarantulas from one
of the fallen stasis spots
and lastly we have the autobots that
confirm once
the first one is optimus prime obviously
the most famous of the transformers and
an all-round good guy well
for the most part if we don't count the
nemesis prime
deal he is the leader of the autobots
and one of the last remaining primes
optimus prime arrived on earth during
the events of bumblebee and will lead
the autobots in upcoming conflicts
then we have bumblebee the most lovable
transformer of all and he will make
another appearance in his upcoming movie
he was one of the first autobots to ever
reach earth and transforms into a camaro
he is a powerful fighter and one of the
most agile of the transformers
then we're gonna see mirage he is an
autobot who transforms into a red
ferrari
and possesses a wide range of
infiltration skills
he has the ability to use an
invisibility cloak and was first seen in
the movie dark of the moon where he
fights and kills quite a number of
decepticons
then we're gonna see rc rc was an
autobot field commander
although never the biggest or toughest
artist of the autobots
she was short and nimble and pack a
punch she transforms into a sports bike
and was first seen in revenge of the
fallen
as helping nes to hunt down decepticons
and so with that we come to the end of
the video the list of the confirmed and
probable transformers that will appear
in the movie rise of the bees
these transformers robots will be a
sight to see
and will set a stage for the events of
the beavers
so till the next one subscribe like
and ring that bell button for regular
updates on new monster videos
take care fam